so  how different was the like  the dynamic of the crew from when you  went into when you got out  when i went in it was already it was  still like fractured  yeah it was it was like everybody doing  their own thing i mean it was like that  before  but we moved as a unit i think fame and  money  it just made like our circle crowded  because now once we all pop  now we all got our entourages and now  it's not just us  it's all of us it's like this entourage  that entourage that entourage so  i don't know i just think maybe it  complicated things but it's all love  it's not like  i think if kim wants to pick up the  phone and call anybody  he could make a dip server union happen  anytime no for sure  yeah nah i think he's got that